The
road to the White House starts in Iowa
and New
for former Vice President Mike Pence.
The early stretch of his race
has been a jog
through a
two mile July 4th parade in Urbandale
and chocolate chip
eating the local sweets in Rule
Northwest Iowa.
It's a serious issue.
One way to deal with them
repairing the personal politics
of local Republicans is wonderful.
It's the only way
you have a chance to really know
how they feel
and answer questions
at your level of the community.
Awesome.
Ten counties sweep for candidate Pence
just this week
as he aims
to hit all 99 counties in Iowa.
What is it
that you hope to achieve
by visiting all these counties,
by doing all of these parades?
You know,
I came to a conclusion
over the last few years
that I'm I'm well known, but
we're not known well,
we're going to be able to
take our story,
take our case,
and take our whole record,
the story of our family
to the people of Iowa, to great success.
The Midwest Native plans
to deliver it over prayer and pizza.
Pence's preferred spot for a slice,
the Pizza Ranch,
a chain with 71 locations across Iowa.
If you want to win the Iowa caucus,
it's a
it's a 50 person Pizza Ranch meeting
because everybody that came here tonight
I guarantee
the one thing they have in common
they're all going to caucus.
Pence National Campaign Chair Chip
Saltsman hatched the so-called Pizza
Ranch strategy in 2008
as campaign manager for then Republican
presidential hopeful Mike Huckabee,
who would come from behind
and win the 2008 Iowa caucuses.
This room believes
Pence's campaign
is how he, too, could win here.
You're looking for people
that are willing to come out
on a cold night.
I spent an hour
and a half
listening to everybody else talk
and then vote for your person.
And the way you build
those relationships
are in meetings of 50,
not rallies of 5000.
In this Pizza
Ranch meeting of 50
Iowans some wearing their allegiance
to a different Republican candidate,
Pence takes
any and all questions from voters,
including one
who confronted him about his role
in certifying
the 2020 election results on January 6th.
Who won that election?
In history?
This one I want to tell you,
with all due respect,
I said before
I said when I announced
President Trump was wrong
about my authority, that
he's still wrong.
I believe it with all my heart.
That answer
only slightly moved Lujan Bertrand,
who asked the question.
I really do feel like he altered history.
Would you consider supporting Mr.
Pence after listening to him?
I would consider it,
but he has that one hiccup.
But meeting Pence did change
Amy Klein's mind.
Well, I voted for Mr.
Trump before.
I know
that I've been going to all of the people
that come that want to run for president.
And so far, I like him the best.
So your opinion has changed
after seeing him up close